ah
hello hello thank you all for joining me
today on my anti-nintendo rant here and
it's been a long time coming let me tell
you
i really appreciate you all coming here
and clicking on this video to share your
hate for this terrible video game
okay guys that was a joke but not like a
funny one
more of a joke used to prove my point
which is that that is
not what we're doing today okay i want
to be very clear that there's going to
be absolutely no hate for nintendo or
their games in this video
this is literally just a list going over
five actual
factual times in the past 34 years that
zelda lore changed from one thing to
another
sometimes even for no reason in
particular other than just because it
fits better and will contain no
criticisms for the company
at all maybe possibly anyway make sure
you comment below which item from this
list sticks out to you and please
consider subscribing to help grow the
channel and liking the video if you
enjoy my content without further ado
here we go
number one wait no let's do it the
opposite way because that makes for much
more suspenseful of a list
number five the placements in the
timeline
whoa starting off big well as most know
by now
the official canon approved timeline is
a thing to say the least it combines the
concept of time travel with the concept
of multiple realities and creates this
just fantastic amalgamation
that you love to look at but hate to
think about and
what if i told you that not only does
this timeline annex games into it as
time goes on
but sometimes nintendo actually just
straight up moves games within the
timeline that already had placements
previously
nope not kidding my example for this is
actually just recently when the remake
of lynx awakening was released last year
prior to the re-uh release link's
awakening actually canonically took
place
after the oracle games located in the
downfall timeline
however now it's located promptly before
them
the only reason i can think of as far as
why nintendo would just
randomly change this would be to
possibly shut down the semi-popular
theory that link actually died at sea at
the end of link's awakening
and forced theorists to realize the
truth that it is in fact
the same ling from link's awakening
experiencing the oracle games oh i'm
sorry was that
a spoiler i i mean i'm sorry but you
know you did click on a video that
specifically mentioned it would delve
into zelda lore and that
okay i'm sorry consider this a spoiler
warning for the rest of the video
up next at number four we have link's
left-handedness
so this is a good one actually because a
lot of zelda fans these days are
actually new to the series
starting from breath of the wild so to
you did you know that link was
originally left handed and i'm not even
talking about like oh man back in the
80s in the first zelda game
if you use a microscope and look at the
two left pixels you can clearly see that
he was left-handed
no i mean like literally in every
iteration of link all the way up until
skyward sword he was specifically
left-handed and i'm not counting
twilight princess's wii version because
that was just a flipped version of the
gamecube one meaning that technically he
was still left-handed so yeah for what
some 25 years link specifically
wielded swords and items in his left
hand which is a trait that's so rare in
real life that it must have been a
deliberate
choice every time they made it and then
it was just dropped to make way for us
right-handed players when nintendo
wanted to introduce the hugely popular
motion controls of skyward sword that
literally
everybody loved and misses to this day
um so yeah it used to be a cool piece of
zelda lore that all links were
left-handed i guess we righties ruined
that one oh by the way if you're
left-handed say hi in the comments below
i'm kind of curious how many of you are
out there actually
number three brings us to ganondorf big
bad familiar ganondorf but not this one
yeah so for whatever reason
in the game four swords adventures which
takes place after ganondorf's death at
the end of twilight princess
instead of using the already existing
trope of reviving ganon which is done
oh you know a couple times here and
there in the downfall timeline nintendo
straight up introduced another ganondorf
that turns into another ganon
this one doesn't exist in any other game
and he doesn't matter to the rest of the
timeline you don't even get to see him
in game before he's already turned into
gannon like
dude that's kind of a big deal that
forces you to change the way you look at
ganondorf
in all other circumstances it's the same
ganondorf that was sealed away at the
end of ocarina of time which is why it's
all about his followers reviving ganon
in the games following a link to the
past
and adds to the significance of his
speeches in wind waker or his
exile in twilight princess but the adult
timeline just had to go introduce this
random reincarnation
of ganondorf instead of introducing i
don't know another enemy which they've
already done many times
and because of this we're posed with
several new problems actually
like does this mean he's essentially
demise's version of the reincarnated
spirit of the hero
like the spirit of the uh demon pig who
knows but either way the change in lore
from one ganondorf to now an
indefinite possibility of ganondorf's
isn't really that appreciated by
theorists and is
one of the reasons why four swords
adventures being a canon game is still
debated in zelda forums to this day
for number two we have the age of the
hero as in what age link has to be to be
able to wield the legendary master sword
and
i guess be considered a hero maybe
anyway this is one of those pieces of
zelda lore that originally wasn't even a
thing but became a thing and then
changed once it was a thing
ahem so the master sword made its first
appearance in the game a link to the
past which obviously wasn't the first
appearance timeline-wise but was the
first time nintendo conceptualized the
legendary blade at the time it was
received
very well with link even being able to
upgrade the legendary blade
twice once he retrieved it from deep
within the lost woods
now fast forward to ocarina of time
which was the first time the master
sword has been seen in
3d when link who for the past 12 years
of zelda gaming has always been shown as
a young child
goes to retrieve the master sword boom
he turns into
an adult but not really an adult because
he's still only like 16 but you know
it's
i guess more adult than being nine why
did this happen you ask
well to quote the sage of light and
part-time santa claus cosplayer rauru
link has been sealed away for seven
years because he was too
young to be the hero of time and this is
actually the core mechanic for the
entire game and the entire timeline
split
so the age that link is considered the
hero worthy of wielding the master sword
is kind of a big
deal and at the time was accepted as the
new normal for the master sword
however the next time the blade is shown
in the series is in wind waker a game
that takes place after ocarina both
legitimately and canonically according
to aeg aunuma
the series director and producer link in
windwaker is canonically
12 years old and guess what he just
picks up that master sword like it's any
other blade obviously you can see the
discrepancy here
link specifically had to be 16 years old
to wield that very weapon in ocarina of
time but in wind waker that requirement
is completely just done away with
if you know the game you might be
tempted to say that it's because the
master sword wasn't powered up when he
picked it up but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah this is a change in lore but i
can't think of a reason why for this one
lastly number one brings us to the very
staple of the series
the golden pinnacle of its symbolism the
triforce
which used to be only two triforces yep
you heard me correctly
in the original legend of zelda the
game's official manual reveals the
discrepancy it reads
a long long time ago the world was in an
age of chaos
in the midst of this chaos in a little
kingdom in the land of hyrule
a legend was being handed down from
generation to generation
the legend of the triforce golden
triangles possessing mystical powers
one day an evil army attacked this
peaceful little kingdom and stole the
triforce of power
this army was led by ganon the powerful
prince of darkness who sought to plunge
the world into fear and darkness under
his rule
fearing his wicked rule zelda the
princess of this kingdom
split up the triforce of wisdom into
eight fragments and hid them throughout
the realm
to save the last remaining triforce from
the clutches of the evil
ganon the last remaining triforce
by the end of the game it's clear that
there are indeed only two pieces in the
original legend of zelda now these days
we can debate lore and say that maybe
link already have the triforce of
courage since ganon had stolen the
triforce of power meaning it probably
split into wisdom power and courage and
went to zelda ganon and link
respectively however it's clear that
from the gameplay
the wording used in the game's manual
and the fact that gannon clearly does
not
care about link's piece of the triforce
and only cares about the last remaining
piece of wisdom
that it was originally intended to only
be the two pieces
oh and by the way it was originally
called the triforce not because there
are three pieces but because
each piece is a triangle this was the oh
g lore change that led to the iconic
triforce symbol we know of today
and that was my list of five times
nintendo
actually straight up changed zelda lore
either for the better for the not so
better or for no reason at all be sure
to like this video if you enjoyed
watching and let me know in the comments
if any of these were new to you or if
there's another change out there that i
missed we all love nintendo very much
and this video was honestly not meant to
criticize them in any way i mean after
all keeping up with one of the only
living and
growing 30 plus year video game
franchises and maintaining a congruent
storyline is probably pretty difficult
and i
very much so appreciate all the hard
work they put into it with that in mind
thank you for watching my humble little
list and as always thank you to my
fantastic supporters for doing what you
do
introducing the new face of perseus who
joined right here on youtube by clicking
that join button below this video
if you're interested in getting your
name up here at the end of each of my
videos well then buddy you're in luck
follow the links in the description
below to find out how also down there
are links to my social media pages so
you know you could follow me or whatever
you know
connect with me more or whatever it's
whatever you know that's all i've got
for this one so i hope you have a great
rest of your day
this is mask nintendo bandit signing out
[Music]
you